Okay. Hi everybody. Good evening.
I hope you're enjoying this great AACR meeting, and it's my
privilege to welcome you tonight to this award
lecture. I'm Dr. Meredith Irwin from the Hospital for Sick
Children in Toronto, and as chair of the AACR Pediatric
Cancer Working Group, it is really my honor and privilege to
preside over the session recognizing this year's recipient of the
AACR St. Baldrick's Foundation Award for Outstanding Achievement
in Pediatric Cancer Research. But first, I would like to
invite Laura Chung, Director of Grants Administration at the St.
Baldrick's Foundation, to the podium to say a few words. Ms. Chung?
All right. Hi everyone. Good evening.
It's my pleasure to just take a moment before we present the award.
As she said, I'm with St. Baldrick's Foundation, and we are proud to partner with
AACR on this award. We're especially proud that this collaboration has
now spanned seven years.
Over that time, we've had the privilege of helping to recognize leaders whose
dedication, curiosity, and persistence have driven real progress
in the field.
This award recognizes something truly special, individuals whose
work has meaningfully advanced our understanding of pediatric cancer or improved
how we treat it. These are the breakthroughs that don't just move science forward,
but ultimately change what's possible for kids and families facing a
cancer diagnosis.
Before I hand the microphone off, I also just want to acknowledge everyone
working in the pediatric cancer research space.
Your efforts are providing so much hope for kids with cancer, and thank you for all
that you do.
Thank you, Ms. Chung. On behalf of the officers and
directors of the AACR board, I would like to thank you and your
colleagues at the St. Baldrick's Foundation for your ongoing collaboration
and partnership that allows the AACR the great opportunity and privilege
to administer this prestigious scientific award.
Thank you again.
This special award was established in 2019 by the
AACR, in partnership with St. Baldrick's, to honor individuals who have
significantly contributed to the advancement of pediatric cancer research,
resulting in fundamental improvement in the understanding and/or treatment of
pediatric cancer.
It is my absolute honor this year to introduce this year's recipient, Dr.
Kimberly Stegmaier. Dr. Stegmaier is the chair of the Department of
Pediatric Oncology at the Dana-Farber Cancer Institute and a leader in
pediatric precision oncology, whose work has been defined by pioneering
discoveries that have transformed the understanding, diagnosis, and
novel therapeutic strategies for many pediatric cancers.
Dr. Stegmaier has made seminal contributions to pediatric cancer
genomics, helping to establish many years ago now that
childhood cancers are genomically and biologically distinct from those
diagnosed in adults and are often driven by fusion oncoproteins and
relatively few mutations. Her work identified important genomic
features of childhood leukemia and Ewing sarcoma, among many others,
revealing new prognostic markers and important mechanistic insights.
She is internationally recognized for her work on fusion oncoprotein
biology. Her studies of Ewing sarcoma have uncovered critical
regulators of the EWS-FLI1 fusion and demonstrated
the importance of the precise levels of these fusion oncoproteins,
opening many new avenues for her research and that of many
others. Dr. Stegmaier has also remarkably been at the
forefront of developing powerful new technologies, including chemical
biology and functional genomic approaches, to identify novel targets
for pediatric cancer research.
She's invented the gene expression-based high-throughput screening, a chemical
genomic strategy that informed the Broad Institute's Connectivity Map and
influenced expression-based discovery approaches more broadly.
She also co-led the first generation of the Pediatric Dependency
Map, which has become a major public resource for identifying therapeutic
vulnerabilities across childhood cancers. Importantly, Dr.
Stegmaier's work has translated her genomic discoveries into clinical
impact. Together with colleagues, she established the Leukemia
Precision Therapy Consortium, also known as LEAP, the first US
multi-institutional genomics-based clinical study for children with relapsed or
refractory leukemia. And her work has also contributed to multiple
clinical trials for children with a wide variety of cancers.
Beyond her scientific accomplishments, Dr.
Stegmaier is a highly respected leader and mentor.
She has served as chair of the St. Jude Scientific Advisory Board, chair
of the AACR Pediatric Cancer Working Group, and as a member of the
AACR Board of Directors, where she represents pediatrics extremely well.
She's deeply committed to training the next generation of researchers, many of
whom now lead independent laboratories and hold leadership roles in
academia and industry. Her many honors include election to the
Association of American Physicians
and the American Society of Clinical Investigation, and just
this week, induction as a fellow of the AACR
Academy.
Dr. Stegmaier exemplifies the ideal of a consummate clinician
scientist, an unwavering clinical dedication with a highly innovative
and creative research program that has fundamentally advanced the
discovery of therapeutic targets across so many pediatric cancers.
It is really my great pleasure and privilege to introduce the
2026 recipient of the AACR St. Baldrick's Foundation
Award for Outstanding Achievement in Pediatric Cancer Research, Dr.
Kimberly Stegmaier.
Thank you, everyone. I'm going to get teary.
So thank you, Meredith. Thank you to St.
Baldrick's, to AACR, to the selection committee.
It is such an incredible honor to be here and to receive
this award this year.
Just one disclosure, but not relevant to this work.
So I think no matter how old you are in this career, and I actually am getting
quite old now,
it's always really important to step back and just thank the people that
really were critical along your career path.
And I want to start by doing that and really thanking Gary Gilliland, Todd
Golub, whom I see out in the audience, and Steve Sallan, who've been three of
my primary mentors over the years.
You heard I just recently became chair in April of this
past year and realized how important all the
leaders of our program have been in helping me along my career
path as well, and want to acknowledge them.
And then in my involvement with AACR, just to say, wow, it's been so
amazing to be on various committees, boards with
Marge Foti, and she has been just an absolute inspiration to me as a
leader.
I want to acknowledge my family because this career is
hard on our families, I think we would agree, and they've been incredibly
supportive of me over the years, my husband, my two children, and just to say
time goes fast because this is my children today.
So what I thought I would do today is take you through a tour
of the work that I've engaged in over the years, really
putting it in a historical context, and also
illustrating how the technologies have really impacted this
field and how they'll continue to impact the field going forward.
And so my first involvement in laboratory-based
investigation was during my medical school days at Harvard,
where I participated in the Howard Hughes Medical Student Program.
And I worked in Gary Gilliland's lab.
Gary is shown here in the blue shirt.
And Todd Golub was a postdoctoral fellow at the time.
And George Barker is the young man in the middle.
He was an MD-PhD student. So Todd had just discovered the TEL
gene, now called ETV6. And during the time in the
lab, we discovered that ETV6 is frequently rearranged
in an ETV6-RUNX1 fusion, previously called TEL AML1,
in about a quarter of childhood ALL.
And the second ETV6 allele is frequently deleted in the presence of
that fusion. And I certainly didn't appreciate, and I actually don't think the
field appreciated, just how common these fusions were to be
in childhood cancers.
This particular fusion, as many of you know, actually is prognostically
important, so this work did have clinical impact.
The ETV6-RUNX1 fusion portends a favorable prognosis in childhood
ALL, and this is work led by Tom MacLean, who was in Gary's lab, as well as
Minyon Lo. And this has held up over time.
So time marches on. Sorry.
This is my favorite picture of Todd
from back in '99. This was on the cover of one of these
Dana-Farber magazines.
But this study to me really, really heralded the
start of the genomics revolution in cancer.
And Todd was the first with Eric Lander to apply these DNA
microarrays to the idea of doing expression profiling in cancer.
And this just brought in this unbelievable omics era, as I like to call
it, where we had this explosion of descriptive data.
This warranted advances immediately in the field of computational
biology to manage the analysis of this data.
And important for the work that I've been doing, there was increasing access to
small molecules and small molecule screening in the context of
academic communities.
And so this first publication that really, I think, marks the start of the
genomics era in cancer was led by Todd
really describing that, yes, we can use these DNA microarrays and
expression signatures to classify disease, in this case, ALL versus
AML. And then there were just a flurry of publications
evaluating this technology, deploying it in work from Scott Armstrong to the
identification of new gene expression classification with
MLL, now called KMT2A, being unique from ALL and AML,
the application to pharmacogenomics in very nice work out of St.
Jude, as well as to outcome prediction in work from Europe.
When I entered my postdoctoral training, which was with
Todd, the project that I took on was to ask, could we
now bring gene expression to small molecule discovery to chemical
biology? And it was the idea that we could use gene expression signatures
as surrogates for different biological states and then adapt those
signatures to high-throughput screening assays.
So we were able to build these assays and then deploy them to a number
of different questions in the context of cancer,
initially looking at differentiation, which led to our identification of
SYK as a target in AML, and there were clinical trials where there were complete
responses to SYK inhibitors, neuroblastoma
differentiation, the idea of modulating transcription
factor abnormalities and their transcriptional outputs, and a number
of other projects, including, as Dr.
Erwin said, the idea of now applying this more systematically
in the context of the Connectivity Map or CMap led by Justin
Lamb at the Broad.
Technologies continue to evolve, and I think an important theme here is in our
research programs, really staying up to speed with new
technologies and deploying them to answer questions.
One of my very strong memories is being in the audience at a meeting where
this first sequencing of an AML genome was presented, and this was work
led by Tim Ley and Elaine Mardis with senior authorship from
Richard Wilson. This again really brought us into a new era
in what we could do in cancer.And so I call this the days
of landscape genomics.
And so I had the privilege of working with Mignonne Lowe and the Broad on
sequencing the genomic landscape of JMML in a project led by Elliot
Daus-Sieglebs.
And this again had prognostic importance in that we
discovered that in children whose JMML had two or more alterations, this
portended a particularly poor prognosis.
As you heard from Meredith, our lab has worked on Ewing sarcoma since the
kind of tail end of my post-doctoral training in Todd Golub's lab.
And I just want to give a little brief background because I'm going to talk about a
few Ewing sarcoma vignettes across this presentation.
So Ewing is the second most common tumor that involves bone in pediatric
patients. And curates for children with localized disease have improved
through the incorporation of additional chemotherapy agents and
interval-compressed chemotherapy.
But our curates for patients with metastatic disease remain very poor.
Nothing that we've done in decades has improved their outcome, and relapse is
nearly always fatal.
Many ways I say this is a canonical pediatric cancer.
It's driven by a fusion oncoprotein.
These are EWS-ETS fusions, most typically
EWS-FLI1. EWS is an RNA-binding protein, but the
RNA-binding domain is not retained in the fusion, but intrinsically disordered
regions are.
And then FLI1 is another ETS transcription factor.
And these fusions are observed in EWS-FLI in about 80 to 90%,
and then there are a smattering of other fusions in this class.
Cell of origin is still debated. There are camps that say mesenchymal, neural
crest. It's possible that it could originate in either.
So work from many people over the years, Steve Leznick,
Miguel Rivera, Sigal Kadosh, Ian Davis, Heinrich Kovar, some work
from our lab, and many others, I should say, has taught us that
this fusion acts as a pioneer transcription factor, and it's really quite
interesting. It establishes de novo enhancers at
GGAA microsatellite repeats, where it acts as a transcriptional
activator, and it recruits the BAF complex to these GGAA repeats.
It's also been reported to compete with typical ETS to repress
gene expression, although that function of the fusion has been less deeply
studied.
And so we also had the privilege of being engaged in
sequencing Ewing sarcoma tumors.
This is work that was led by Brian Crompton when he trained in my lab, and Brian
now leads a lab at Dana-Farber focused on liquid biopsy.
We had the pleasure of collaborating in this work with Gaddy Getz's team, as
well as with John Marmura.
And what emerged from this sequencing effort is this finding that
recurrent mutations are really very few in pediatric cancers, and this was one
of the earlier studies to do that. We had two other
groups that were similarly engaged in sequencing efforts around that same time from
Mike Dyer and Olivier Delattre, as well as Javed Khan.
And it was very reassuring to see that all three groups really came to very similar
conclusions.
So these, as we said, these somatic mutations are
relatively low disease burden or quiet genomes across many
childhood cancers. In fact, most, as shown here, compared to adult.
And I think as we know now, we see structural abnormalities in childhood
cancers more than many somatic mutations.
Another finding from this work was that there were recurrent mutations in the
gene STAG2. And again, this was seen across all three of the studies.
So STAG2 is a member of the cohesin complex, which has a number of
functions in the cell, including gene regulation.
And these mutations tend to lead to an absence of the STAG2 protein.
So once again, this is an example where the genomic
sequencing has clinical impact through its bearing
as a prognostic marker. And so multiple groups now, including as
shown here, Dave Shulman, in a study led out of Brian Crompton's
lab, and also Riaz Gillani and a number of authors, have
shown again and again that these mutations are a poor prognostic feature.
And this will really be the first genomic
biomarker of poor outcome in Ewing sarcoma, so really important.
So we made an observation in our initial sequencing
study that the patients who had tumors that had an absence of
STAG2 protein had a higher incidence of metastatic disease, and we
aim to study that further in the lab.
So Biniam Madani, another very talented trainee who worked with us, who is
now at BMS, and Gabriela Alexe, who is a very senior
and outstanding data scientist in the lab, worked on this study together.
And so Biniam generated a series of isogenic models where he knocked out
STAG2 to mimic the impact of the mutations and was able to
demonstrate that this promoted metastatic disease.
And at the same time as we published this work, Didier Surdez in
Olivier Delattre's lab published very similar findings that the loss of
STAG2 was associated with migratory and invasive
behavior.
And so we also began to probe, well, what might the mechanisms be behind
this observation? And so we looked at RNA sequencing after
knocking out STAG2 in Ewing sarcoma cell line models.
And then we also looked at data from a number of different primary tumor
studies. And again and again, what we saw is that the absence of STAG2
was actually associated with a repression of parts of the EPHLIP
signature.
And this was in part due to alterations in 3D chromatin.
And again, Olivier's lab found very similar findings in their
study.
And so this was exciting to us because there was an emerging literature from a
number of different laboratories that the dosage of EPHLIP matters.
It matters in terms of the cell state.
And one of the findings across a number of groups that was quite consistent with
what we were observing in these primary tumors related to STAG2
is that when you lower EPHLIP levels, not shut it off completely, but lower
it, that tends to be associated with more mesenchymal-like
migratory invasive
behavior.So
time continues to march on. We went from sort of landscape
genomics, then to functional genomics.
And I'm borrowing this analogy from Bill Hahn, who likes cars,
and says, "You can identify the parts of a car and
name them, but do we know how they work?" And technologies such as RNAi and
CRISPR really allowed us to go from characterizing landscapes to
now functionalizing on a genome scale.
And so we were very fortunate to be involved in the
dependency map work at the Broad Institute.
It was really very exciting to me that this year the AACR Team Science
Award was to the DepMap team led now by Paquita Vazquez.
And so our work in PDET really built upon this much larger
work around dependency map that was led by Bill Hahn and David Root and
others in the early days. So I think it's an idea familiar to most people in the
audience that we can take cancer models.
Primarily, this has been done with cancer cell lines, and profile their genetic
molecular features and then perturb them systematically with
RNAi or CRISPR or small molecules, build computational
pipelines, and then use that type of data to either nominate therapeutic
hypotheses or it's actually informing us quite a bit about
the underlying mechanisms of these cancers.
And so now over 10 years ago, we had the opportunity to really build
out the pediatric component of this together with Paquita Vazquez and also
Charlie Roberts at the time when he was at Dana-Farber.
And just very briefly, I'm going to focus first on the CRISPR element of this data.
These are genome-scale screens. They use two to four
guides per gene, depending on the library, and over 1,000 cancer
cell line models have been screened.
And I think very importantly, the data's made public before there's actually a
new publication. And so this is really a living data set that continues to get
updated as more models are screened.
And these screens are generally done at a 21-day time point.
And we've been most interested in guides like this that drop out, as they
might represent a gene that when deleted, has a deleterious effect on those
cancer cells. I think it's important to also mention there are other groups that
have been engaged in DepMap-like work, including the Sanger, as well as a really
nice effort in Australia led by Ron Firestein.
So one of our first tasks when we built this first data set, which included a
little over 80 pediatric cancer models,
was to ask some fundamental questions.
First, some people would ask us, "Well, pediatric cancers, they don't have that
many mutations. Maybe they actually don't have that many
dependencies." And that turned out not to be true.
So pediatric cancers have as many dependencies as adult cancers.
And this first build of this project was led on a
computational side by Nikesh Dharia, a really talented pediatric
oncologist, cross-trained in computational biology as well as Lily
Guenther, another really talented pediatric oncologist.
And so Nikesh is now at Genentech, and Lily is running her own
lab at St. Jude. And Lily led this effort on the biology
side.
And so another finding from this work is that many pediatric
cancers, although I'll show you not all, have a very
striking dependence retained on lineage-related
transcription factors. And these are, in fact, often the top
dependencies that are selective in that childhood cancer compared to all the other
cancers that have been screened. And this is very strikingly the
case for neuroblastoma.
In work that we collaborated on with Tom Look's lab as well as
Rick Young's lab that was led by Adam Durbin, Nikesh Dharia, as well as
Mark Zimmerman, really showed that in neuroblastoma,
these transcription factors form what's called a coregulatory circuit,
where they self-regulate, they're marked by super enhancers, they're highly
expressed, and then they regulate one another.
And now that we had the DepMap data, we were able to show for the first time that
these coregulatory transcription factors are also really strong
dependencies in this disease.
I also want to acknowledge there were two other really beautiful papers that
preceded ours that also contributed to defining this idea of
coregulatory circuitry in neuroblastoma and looked at both an adrenergic
state, which is shown here in this image, but also a more
mesenchymal state. And so this idea that there's heterogeneity in
state in neuroblastoma as well as other cancers is another major
theme that has emerged over the years.
So these are hard to drug. So these are hard to make small molecule
targeted therapies against. But this work, I think, is still important even
while we try to make drugs against them for other reasons.
And so this is a really amazing study from Mark
Yermakovich in John Marras's lab that looked at the
targeting of intracellular oncoproteins with peptide-centric
CARs. And so one of the targets that they focused on was
FOX2B, which was the same target I showed you as part of a coregulatory
circuit and a strong dependency in neuroblastoma.
And to me, this is really a perfect target and that the cells require this target
for ongoing proliferation. And so now we can even use data like
DepMap to intersect that with data looking at
peptide-centric CAR technology, cell surface technology, et cetera.
I also want to mention that this idea of state
heterogeneity is really important, we think, in terms of
response to therapy, whether it be immunotherapy or small molecule
therapy. And this was work that Nathaniel Mabe led out of my lab in a
very close collaboration with Robbie Masner's lab, and Min Huang was
Nathaniel's partner in this work.
That showed that in the adrenergic state of neuroblastoma, these cells have higher
levels of GD2 and tend to be more responsive to
GD2-directed therapy. But in the mesenchymal state, GD2
levels are lower.
And then in work from a number of years ago by Mandy Babone Iniguez
showing that, yes, state also matters, and you can see
enhancer rewiring and this state switch in the context of
small molecule targeted therapies as well.
So again, I think this is a very important theme as we think about drug
resistance.So we were
really optimistic when we started this project and we had the neuroblastoma
data, and we saw this observation in things like AML and rhabdo that
these tumors retain dependency on core regulatory circuitry
that we might use this type of data to identify the cell of origin of
Ewing sarcoma. And I will say that turned out to be an utter failure.
We did not see that at all . And in fact, what we saw was something quite
different. So these tumors certainly depend on the fusion,
as guides directed against FLI and EWS-R1 score very strongly.
There's also a very strong paralog relationship.
When you lose STAG2, you're dependent on STAG1.
And then we found two other targets that I'll discuss.
But what you don't see are highly expressed activating
transcription factors that mark lineage.
And I was really excited when Didier Surdace actually published this paper that
really speaks to this in a more formal way.
And I love the use of the word hegemonic.
So the hegemonic EWS-R1/ETS oncoprotein overrules
core regulatory circuitry principles in Ewing sarcoma.
And we absolutely agree with this.
And I just love the title, so I wanted to share it.
And I think for those of you who've worked on Ewing for a long time, this tumor
just doesn't follow the rules, I'm going to say.
So what we saw instead was this extremely strong Goldilocks
phenomena in Ewing, where the tumors depend on a very
precise level of the fusion. If you fully repress it, it's very
deleterious. If you overexpress it or manipulate it in other ways, that is
also equally deleterious. And while we've focused on this in Ewing, this is
clearly emerging as a theme across other oncogene signaling
pathways, and there's a community that's growing around this concept.
And so one of the first targets that we focused on was TRIM8,
and obviously it's scoring very strongly in the dependency map screening.
It also scored as a top hit in a flow-based screen that we did
using a reporter model reporting out on EWS-FLI levels.
So in this screen, the loss of TRIM8 was predicted to increase
EWS-FLI levels.
And so what is TRIM8? TRIM8 is an E3 ligase.
It has a ring domain. And I think when we think about this target
from a therapeutic window, importantly, the TRIM8 knockout mouse was
viable, and TRIM8 in the first build of the data only scored
in Ewing sarcoma. It didn't score in any other disease, suggesting, again,
really selective dependency. So this work was led by Alex Song,
again, really talented trainee who worked with us, and Alex is now
at AstraZeneca.
And so what Alex went on to show both in vitro and in vivo is that knockout
of TRIM8 had a very strong phenotype.
This is showing some data from an in vivo model.
And indeed did regulate EWS-FLI levels.
And so when he knocked out TRIM8, EWS-FLI goes up.
We saw this across every model that we evaluated with the fusion.
NKX2-2 goes up. That's a direct target of the fusion.
And importantly, wild-type EWS doesn't change, and as shown in the
other figure, wild-type FLI does not change.
So we think this effect is specific to the fusion and not the wild-type
counterparts.
And so in the interest of time, I'm just going to show you one more figure panel on
this target. We also did a series of experiments to look at
what overexpression does to these cells, and this is a very simple one where we
just used a dox-inducible system to overexpress the fusion.
And consistently, this was deleterious, inducing annexin-positive cell
death. And this wasn't just an in vitro artifact.
When we overexpress the fusion, including in patient-derived xenograft
models, it's similarly very deleterious in vivo.
So we also identified a second target that spoke to this
Goldilocks phenomenon. This is work that Diana Lu led from the lab.
Diana did her MD-PhD studies with us, again, another
extremely talented trainee.
And so Diana got interested in ETV6, and I was, of course,
excited about this target because this is the first gene that I actually worked on
as a medical student.
And so ETV6, as I said, is a master developmental transcription factor.
It's a repressor in hematopoiesis, and it is recurrently
mutated in hematologic malignancies, as I showed you in the
ETV6-RUNX1 case, but also in other heme malignancies
and beyond heme malignancies. And it has a
DNA-binding domain that binds to GGAA motifs.
And so Diana went on to show that the knockout of ETV6
inhibits Ewing sarcoma growth, colony formation, and tumor
progression in vitro and in vivo, using both CRISPR knockout
systems as well as dTAG systems.
And she also showed that in Ewing, as observed in hematopoiesis,
ETV6 is a transcriptional repressor.
So here she used a dTAG system so she could acutely degrade ETV6
and then ask what happens to gene expression, and gene expression indeed
goes up.
And the programs were quite consistent across multiple Ewing sarcoma
models.
So what she observed in this context is that when we looked at gene
pathways, EWS-FLI signatures were now going up very
strongly.
And so this felt, again, to us like another Goldilocks phenomenology.
And so she hypothesized that because ETV6 is an S
transcription factor, FLI is an S transcription factor, that
perhaps the fusion and ETV6 were found at similar sites on chromatin.
And that's, in fact, what she found, that ETV6 colocalizes
with FLI on chromatin, and when you now remove
ETV6, you degrade it, you get an excess of
EWS-FLI on chromatin. And she went on to show even that she could rescue
this phenomenology by knocking out individual
genes.And so we were pretty
excited when Chris Vakoc called us up to ask what did we think of
ETV6 in Ewing sarcoma, and we were like, "Well, Chris, what do you think about it?"
And so he had very similar data, and so we were pretty
excited. I always like when other labs are working on the same thing because it
means that you're probably onto something that's very robust.
And so we both published together, in "Nature Cell Biology," and Beth
Lawler, with April Affelbaum training in her lab, wrote this really lovely on
"News and Views" that I think summarizes this quite nicely, that the
fusion and ETV6 actually are competing on chromonin.
ETV6 is constraining how much Ephi is found on chromonin,
and when you remove ETV6, you get excess Ephi on chromonin,
that's deleterious to Ewing cells.
And Chris also focused on a differentiation phenotype in that context.
So I'd like to mention some of the other types of dependencies that we and
others have identified in the context of DepMap.
And one that I think is actually particularly of interest in pediatric
cancers are paralog relationships.
And this is the idea that you have two paralogous genes, and when
one is lost or repressed, cells can acquire exquisite
dependency on the other.
And one of the earliest papers that I saw on this in specific targets
in childhood cancers was actually from Charlie Roberts' lab, demonstrating that
ARID1B is a specific vulnerability in ARID1A mutant
cancers. And this is now held up across multiple other studies.
Many groups now have shown that this STAG1, STAG2
paralog relationship is really quite strong, and I think these are all quite good
targets for these childhood cancers.
Really lovely work from Claire Malone, who trained in my lab.
Claire's now at InduPro and leading a clinical trial, which I think is really
exciting about her company. It's very exciting.
Claire worked on NXT1 and showed that NXT1 is a
paralog with NXT2, and that these neuroblastoma cells and
other cancers that have profound repression of NXT2 are very
strongly dependent on NXT1. And again, I think this is a really
exciting target. And then finally, VRK1.
Our group published this with Bill Hahn and Mariella Filbin.
There are other independent groups focused on this target.
VRK1 is a synthetic lethal target in VRK2 promoter
methylated cancers of the nervous system, including brain tumor
subsets, and neuroblastoma.
And so with sort of this early phase of pediatric DepMap and proof
of concept demonstrating the importance, we were super excited to be
able to take this to a new level in a collaboration across the Broad
Institute led by Paquita Vazquez, St.
Jude, led by Charlie Roberts, and our team at Dana-Farber, and many, many
investigators making critical contributions to this.
This has really been, to me, an amazing collaborative effort.
One of our goals has been to try to expand screening into
models that we were unable to screen before, and this has been a huge success of
this project over the last few years.
We've more than tripled the number of childhood cancer models that were screened.
We've been able to screen in hemolignancy models not screenable before, as
well as in a number of brain tumor models, including DMG as
one example.
So I want to end this last part talking about
therapeutics and the challenges and some of the directions that we're
taking on therapeutic work in our own lab.
So I think we would all agree there are many challenges involved in
developing therapies in pediatric oncology.
Just to mention a few, these transcription factors are
such important drivers, and they make for very challenging drug targets.
These diseases have a low mutational burden, so generally, they've not
been responsive to immune checkpoint inhibitors.
These are rare and ultra-rare cancers, so there's a lack of market
incentive for developing drugs. And it's been estimated that about
half of pediatric cancer drivers are unique to pediatric cancers,
so there's no market incentive for this.
So what are some of the tactics that we and others have been taking?
One was,
is there low-hanging fruit, right?
And so this was a project led by Yana Pickman in my
lab, and Yana now also has an independent lab at
Dana-Farber focused on leukemia clinical genomics.
And so together we formed the Pediatric LEAP
Consortium, included 15 institutions.
It was very generously supported by the St. Baldrick's Foundation.
We could not have done this without their support.
And we built this team of folks that worked incredibly well collaboratively
together to bring in the early days of having clinical genomics
tests to children with high-risk relapse
refractory leukemia. And we greatly benefited from the pioneering work of
Katie Janeway in getting this all off the ground.
And so with this study, we asked a very simple question: Can we
identify lesions that are immediately targetable with available drugs?
And in some cases, the answer was yes, and this is just one example of a
dramatic responder. This was a 10-year-old child who was diagnosed with
B-ALL, and she got standard chemotherapy and then
unfortunately relapsed. She had salvage chemo, she had a bone marrow
transplant, and she had CAR T therapy.
And with each of these, she had a relapse.
And she came to our institute, she had genomic
studies, and we found that she had an RCST1 ABL2
fusion in her leukemia cells, and this was predicted to respond to
imatinib. And so we were able to incorporate imatinib
into a backbone regimen that she was actually not responding to the chemotherapy
alone, but went into a complete remission. She had a transplant.
She stayed on imatinib, and now many, many years later, she remains in a
complete remission. So for this child, this type of clinical genomic study
was critical to her long-term survival.
But we know that these kinase fusions and kinase point mutations tend to
be more rare in childhood cancers, and so we need to still tackle the
harder challenges.And so one of the strategies that we have
been exploring recently is an arm of the dependency map
that I think is a little bit less well explored than the CRISPR arm, and
that's the chemical screening arm of this work.
Which uses prism screening, which was an approach established by
Channing Yu in Todd Golub's lab, and then Steve Corsello did a lot of work to
really bring this
type of screening to bioactive and FDA-approved drug
collections. And so what prism is, it's taking cancer cell
lines, it's barcoding them, and then it's pooling them in collections of up
to 25 models that have similar growth properties, and then screening
them against decks of molecules. And so to date, in the order of
800 plus cancer models have been screened against thousands of drugs.
And so Toby Alloway, a very talented chemist who is learning
chemical biology in our lab, asked a question in the way that we ask
the CRISPR data. Are there molecules that are more active in Ewing
than in all the other cancer models that have been screened?
And what Toby found is that this molecule, R112, is
very highly active in Ewing compared to everything else.
And ironically, this was reported as a spleen tyrosine kinase inhibitor target
I had worked on in AML. But in Ewing sarcoma, this is absolutely not the
target. You can knock out SYK and the cells don't care.
And in fact, all of the reported kinases that are targets of this molecule, none
of them are relevant in Ewing sarcoma.
So Toby went on, and he validated this finding, though, that the Ewing
sarcoma models are very responsive.
Other sarcomas that are non-Ewing are not responsive, and Ewing is really the most
responsive of all of the models that were screened.
And so to try to identify the targets, what he did here is he used
a CRISPR rescue screening strategy where he used
CRISPR to knock out each gene in the genome and then said, "Loss of what genes
rescues the effects of this molecule?"
And what he found is that there's incredibly strong reliance on
UDP glucose metabolism for the activity of this molecule.
And in particular, we showed that the knockout of
UGT3A2 fully rescues the effect of the compound.
And so this is essential to the activity.
And while we don't have all the answers yet, what I thought was really exciting is
UGT3A2 is wildly overexpressed in Ewing.
It's a direct target of the fusion.
It's not expressed in most cancers, and it's not expressed in most normal cells.
So we think a really interesting mechanism.
I think the target's a bystander of the
fusion, but it's rendering exquisite response to the molecule, and we're still
trying to figure out the actual details of mechanistically at a more
granular level, how does this work.
So in the last two minutes, I just want to mention a few thoughts on the
therapeutic targeting of the actual fusion.
And so we and many people are excited about the idea of using
targeted protein degradation. There have been a number of exciting talks at the
meeting about this topic. There are two primary flavors of this.
One is bifunctional degraders, also called PROTACs or proteolysis
targeting chimeras, where you have a ligand to your protein, a linker, and
a ligand to an E3 ligase.
Importantly, you still need a ligand to your protein of interest, so it's not like
a 100% solution. You still have to find that.
But there are a number of molecules that are in the clinic now.
Two, just to name AR and ER PROTACs.
They've been active and safe and tolerated.
The other type of degrader are molecular glue-like degraders.
These are monovalent molecules that bind a target.
They bind an E3 and bring them in proximity, leading to degradation.
And thalidomide and lenalidomide are two examples of these types of molecules.
So we've been taking a strategy with Eric Fisher's lab to develop
EWS-FLI GFP reporter models that also express
mCherry to adapt this to high-throughput screening and then to screen in
the order of over 100,000 molecules for molecules that by
image-based readouts lead to loss of the fusion protein.
And so we've put the first series of hits through a number of different assays, and
we have several molecules that are still holding up across the assays.
I'm just showing you, and I'll just describe this one here, where we see a
really nice dose-responsive effect now in Ewing cells on the fusion.
We see loss of NKX2.2 in a dose-responsive way, the direct target of the
fusion. And this effect on viability as well as on GFP
and mCherry can be rescued with a proteasome inhibitor, suggesting that the
mechanism is likely vis-a-vis degradation.
So a lot more work to do, but I think encouraging.
And in the last few minutes, I just want to talk about another avenue that we're
excited about. And I was really excited to see a number of talks at this
meeting on this idea of using bifunctional
molecules in new and interesting ways.
And so this was a paper that was published by Nat Gray and
Jerry Crabtree's lab that asked the question: Could you rewire
cancer drivers to activate apoptotic cell death?
And so here what they did is they took a bifunctional molecule that
has a ligand for BRD4, has a linker and a ligand for
BCL6. And they asked could they bring
BRD4 to BCL6, and could they now turn
on BCL6 repressed targets and induce cell death.
And so they were able to show that indeed they can turn on BCL6 repressed
targets in contexts such as lymphoma and induce cell death.
So we were part of a U54 consortium where
Nat Gray was engaged in this work with Jerry Crabtree's lab, and we started talking
about could we do just a proof of concept study in Ewing.
This is not a therapy. It's just proof of concept to ask the
question: Can we start moving EWS-FLI around on
chromatin using bifunctional chemistry?
And so this work was led by Mike Bond, another chemist who is
training in my lab, as well as a terrific team, Julia DiGiovanni and
Brianna Howard. Julia is a data scientist.
Brianna was a Harvard undergrad.And so we said, we don't have a
great ligand for EWS-FLI, so we're going to engineer cells
to express the fusion with an FKBP
mutant. And then what we did is we used bifunctional molecules
that had a ligand for the FKBP mutant, a linker, and a
ligand for BCL6.
And we said, can we now drag EWS-FLI to BCL6 repressed
genes in Ewing? We don't think BCL6 is a great target for Ewing.
This was just merely proof of concept.
There was a EbtSIH is the active compound, lots of controls that I'm not going
to talk about in the interest of time.
So we defined BCL6 repressed genes.
One I'm going to just show you some data on was SOX2.
I didn't think this would work, but it actually did.
I was very pleasantly surprised. So this is just showing the SOX2
locus. When we treat with the bifunctional molecule, we
gain E-FLI on chromatin pretty specifically.
We see really nice opening of chromatin by ATAC-seq, and we
see a gain in gene expression of SOX2.
We see the same for CISH and a number of other targets.
So I think in principle, this could work.
There are many applications now for bifunctional molecules. This is just one.
But I think this is a pretty exciting area for pediatric oncology.
So this is kind of where we are now. This is what our lab does.
We work on fusion oncoprotein biology, discovery of novel targets and
molecules, mechanisms of response and resistance across a number of
childhood cancers, and trying to stay nimble as new technologies
evolve.
Just some final comments. We've learned a ton over the years.
We know these are cancers that have gone awry
developmentally. They often retain dependency on these key
lineage core regulatory circuit transcription factors.
Cell state plasticity really is important in response to therapies.
Typically, childhood cancers have few recurrent point mutations.
Fusion oncoproteins are really common.
EWS-FLI and other oncogenes, I do think, have a strong Goldilocks
phenomena that we might be able to leverage through an activation lethality
mechanism. And I think there are a lot of exciting opportunities now in
therapy, from exploiting paralogs and developmentally restricted
targets to leveraging this new degrader technology and other bifunctional
molecules.
I want to just end by thanking my lab.
This award is really more about the people that trained
with you than it is, I would argue, about the individual leading the lab.
And so I've been so fortunate to work with incredible trainees over
the years. It's also wonderful to have great collaborators.
This to me is also what makes this job so fun.
I want to thank our many funding sources over the years.
We surely couldn't do this without them.
And then just want to end with some fun photos.
I've been just the most fortunate PI to work with just
consistently amazing and kind and collaborative trainees over
the years. So happy to take questions now or offline. Thank you.
So great lecture, Kim, and very deserving of the award.
I was geeking out a little bit about some of the latter stuff that you're doing and
some stuff that's been here about rewiring using the bifunctionals.
And the specific example that you've shown where you're linking
EWS to a transcriptional repressor, wouldn't you also repress
EWS-activated genes?
Yeah.
That should be in your same data set.
I'm glad you asked the question. So we asked the same question.
What we do see is that you bring BCL6 to EFLI target genes,
but you do not get great repression.
And there are two possibilities there, right?
One is that the molecule that's the ligand for BCL6 does have
inhibitory activity. So it could be that.
The other could be that EFLI is such a strong transcriptional
activator that it may be harder to actually repress that fusion output than it
is to activate expression at a target that's repressed.
And so we don't have, I would say this is our NO1 study.
We don't have lots more data to address that, but that was our observation.
BCL6 is there, but it's not really repressing.
You might also have a stoichiometry problem, right?
That's possible.
Because of multi-binding.
Absolutely. Yep. A great question.
Really great talk, as always. I'm so fascinated by the
bifunctional molecule as well as you know.
What do you think is your,
based on your knowledge right now, your feeling on what are we going
to be able to target this way? Is it highly expressed fusions?
Is it highly expressed
even mutated proteins?
Right.
What's your feeling on those?
Because if we can, that might open up a whole new box of
tools for our cancers.
I agree. So you may have seen,
there's a
lot we don't know, I think to start with.
I do think
going after the fusions to me is very important because whenever
we have had molecules that target the fusions, those molecules have been active,
right? Whether it's like PML retinoic acid receptor alpha-
Right
... all the kinase fusions, like consistently, I can't think of a
time when we had good chemistry and it wasn't active in the disease.
So I think that we need to continue to push on that.
And I showed one strategy, which is looking for glu-like degraders.
There are other teams that are looking for direct ligands using DEL screens
and other strategies, right? So I think we need to continue to press on that.
I think this question around bifunctionals and some of the work that we
talked about around this RIP-TAG idea,
I think is very intriguing. So there were some nice presentations here on these
molecules that
are bifunctional for AR or ER and then for BRD4,
and have actually now shown activity in clinical trial.I think there, to me,
the question is we don't yet know all the rules, right?
Those are both nuclear proteins. They're good ligands.
Could you imagine a ligand for a target that's highly
expressed, for example, in Ewing or neuroblastoma that we have a ligand for that's
nuclear and hooking that up to something that recruits BRD4?
I think those are really interesting ideas that we have to think a little more
deeply about as to what are the targets and are there ligands.
But I think that there's so many interesting things we could try now.
But we're going to have to define the rules, I think, as we go.
But yeah, great question. I'm open.
We should talk more.
Exciting times. Thank you.
Great. Hey, Katie.
Hi, Kim. Great talk and well deserved.
Congratulations on the award.
My question for you, there have been
several sessions at the meeting today about the challenges of drug development
in pediatric oncology and sort of the math not adding up.
So my question for you is any of these, like the PROTACs or these
bifunctional molecules,
do any of these approaches for transcription
factor fusion solve the math problem?
Are any of them sort of like CAR T-cells where we can own the development?
Yeah. So I think it's
not a yes/no answer. I think in some cases, right,
we'll kind of use menin as an example where
initially that was thought to only be KMT2A rearranged leukemias, and
then, well, it turns out it's not really just the fusion, it's high HOX,
and that includes NPM1, which is really common in adults, and well, now it's
NUP98, now it's UBTF, and now many companies are working
on menin, right? So I think there will be cases where
you kind of open up the space and then you have the tool molecules,
and that makes all these studies much easier, and you have bigger and bigger
DepMap-type studies, and the market becomes bigger.
So I think that's one possibility.
Some of the targets that we discovered and worked on in pediatrics, like
VRK1, is relevant in adult brain tumors, right?
And it's across multiple diseases.
NXT1, Claire worked on primarily neuroblastoma and
RABDO, but it is relevant in pancreatic cancer.
So I think some of these targets will have broader markets.
I think the question about if you had something that was
specific only to EWS-FLI, and it didn't have
relevance beyond those specific fusions, how do you do
that? And I think there, my feeling is there's
such strong dependencies that if you had truly a
really good molecule, the specificity should be good
and the activity should be good. And we don't know yet whether
that's a short-term treatment, a chronic treatment, like a Gleevec.
We don't know, really, what will the sort of market
plan be long term. So I personally just think we have to figure
out how to do it, whether it's collaboration between public and
private. But we want to get-- I mean, obviously we want to get
away from doing a year of five-drug chemotherapy.
I
like the optimism. That was a good antidote to those sessions.
Thank you, Katie.
Maybe a last question.
Sure.
Hi, Kim. Great lecture. Nice perspective. I had a more fundamental question.
I was wondering, why do you think pediatric cancers exhibit
more of a fusion protein-
Ah
... oncogenes than the adult cancers, while they go through more-
Yeah
... cell cycle?
It's a great question. Meredith is
nodding.
I don't know the answer, but some thoughts.
Part may be the tolerance of the
fusions, right? That you have developing cells that are more
tolerant, and that the fusions occur at some background rate
in other cells, in adults, in other dividing cells, but they're
not tolerated, they're not transforming. So that's a possibility.
I think the second question is, are there moments in development where the
background rate of the formation of a fusion is different in a certain
cellular context, right? I think that's another question.
So I don't know the answer. I think it's a fascinating question, and I think
there's increasing data that these fusions occur in utero in a
number of different cancers, some published, some not published.
So,
whether it's, again, development and incidence of fusion, we know
that there's a tolerance issue, right?
That we know, that certain in Ewing, most things don't
tolerate. Even neural crest cells and mesenchymal stem cells don't tolerate it
really, right? They barely do. So I think it's probably both developmental window,
but this other question about the occurrence of fusions in
development, I think, is an interesting one.
Thank you.
Yeah.
So with that, I think I want to just congratulate and thank Kim again for an
amazing talk.
Thank you.